>> THE FUN OF MARCH MADNESS, THE
UPSETS AND SISTER JEAN.
WANT HER IN YOUR CORNER.
>>> WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
BREAKING NEWS OVERNIGHT THAT
COULD PAVE THE WAY FOR A FOURTH
COVID VACCINE IN THIS COUNTRY.
ASTRAZENECA SAYS A NEW STUDY IN
THE U.S. FOR TWO OTHER COUNTRIES
SHOWS THAT ITS VACCINE IS 79%
EFFECTIVE AT PREVENTING COVID
SYMPTOMS.
THE COMPANY SAYS IT'S 100%
EFFECTIVE AT STOPPING SEVERE
ILLNESS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THE U.S. HAS PREORDERED 300
MILLION DOSES OF THE VACCINE.
FOR MORE LET'S BRING IN DR.
DAVID AGUS.
THANK YOU FOR GETTING UP EARLY.
THIS IS REALLY BIG NEWS.
IS THERE A BUT TO THE NEWS?
I ONLY ASK BECAUSE THERE WAS,
YOU KNOW, CONCERN IN EUROPE
ABOUT BLOOD CLOTS WITH THIS
VACCINE.
HOW DOES IT STACK UP AGAINST THE
OTHERS?
>> I THINK IT'S GREAT.
SO 32,000 PEOPLE RANDOMIZED, AND
WHAT IT SHOWED IS IT WORKED.
THERE WAS NO BLOOD CLOTS SEEN IN
THE STUDY OVER PLACEBO.
THERE WERE NO SYMPTOMS.
MONTH AGO WE THOUGHT THERE MAY
BE A NEUROLOGIC UPTICK, AND IT
TURNED OUT TO BE INCORRECT.
SO IN EUROPE NOW, THESE BLOOD
CLOTS TURNED OUT NOT TO BE
RELATED TO THE VACCINE.
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THIS
VACCINE, BUT FINALLY IT'S HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S ALREADY OUT IN DOZENS OF
COUNTRIES AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT THREE
VERY STRONG VACCINES IN THIS
COUNTRY.
SO IF ASTRAZENECA IS APPROVED,
HOW WILL THIS DRUG IMPACT THE
TIMELINE TO VACCINATE EVERY
AMERICAN?
>> WELL, IT CAN ONLY HELP.
WE HAVE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOSES OF THIS READY TO GO.
IT WILL TAKE ANOTHER SIX TO
SECRETARY OF WEEKS TO GET THE --
SIX TO SEVEN WEEKS TO GET THE
VACCINE OUT, BUT THESE DOSES ARE
CRITICAL.
I THINK MOST CRITICAL IS THAT
THIS IS A VACCINE WHERE THERE
ARE THREE BILLION DOSES ORDERED
FOR THE WORLD.
REMEMBER, WITH THIS VIRUS, IF
THERE'S AN INFECTION SOMEELSE IN
THE WORLD, IT CAN SPAWN A NEW
VARIANT AND AFFECT US.
IT MATTERS THAT THERE ARE
VACCINES AVAILABLE FOR OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THIS IS A BIG SHOT IN THE ARM
FO THEM AND BOOST OF CONFIDENCE
FOR THE GLOBE.
VERY EXCITED THAT WE HAVE
ANOTHER WEAPON IN OUR ARSENAL.
>> I LIKE WHAT Y